PROFESSOR: All right, I feel
almost as though I should
introduce myself
all over again.
It's been a week and a half
since we had a lecture.
So let me begin by reminding
you of what we were doing.
We had derived all of the plane
groups, and for better
or worse had put
them behind us.
And then we moved into three
dimensions, where things get a
lot more involved and a lot more
complicated, and to say
the least, a lot
more numerous.
And the first question we asked
was to say, when we're
in a three-dimensional space,
we can combine a first
rotation operation with a second
rotation operation, B
beta If we're to begin by
deriving point groups-- that
is to say, the least [INAUDIBLE]
point in this
three-dimensional space
is not going to move.
[INAUDIBLE]
two axes to intersect a point.
For a space group, they could
be parallel to one another.
But that's gonna be an infinite
set of symmetry
elements and operations that
extends through all space.
Then we asked the question--
rhetorically, because you knew
I was going to answer--
what is the net result of a
sequence of rotating from a
first object to a second, and
then picking up the second and
rotating it to an angle beta
about second axis.
Begin the third one here.
What is the net effect?
And again, we could do that by
the process of elimination.
It has to be either translation
or another
rotation, because these are the
only two generic sorts of
operations which leaves the
chirality unchanged.
And I think I convinced you
that indeed there was some
third axis, C, which rotated
directly from the first to the
third by some different
angle, gamma.
So that is the consequence of
combining the first two
rotation axes.
What they would anticipate is
that the location and also the
value of the rotation
[INAUDIBLE] depends on alpha
and beta, and also [INAUDIBLE]
at which we combine them.
And that's what we'll see.
You could do this in a number
of ways that if you don't
[INAUDIBLE]
that gamma would turn
out to be a
crystallographic rotation.
And then your result would be
true, but it would not be a
rotation operation which could
exist in a three-dimensional
point group.
So using the genius of
Leonhard Euler and a
construction known as Euler's
construction.
We set up a little spherical
triangle,
which we could analyze.
Let me tell you a little bit
about Euler, because he's a
remarkable individual.
The first remarkable feature of
Euler is that he's Swiss,
and there are not many
world-class famous people who
are Swiss, simply because the
population is so small.
The probability of somebody
rising to heights is constant
among all populations.
If you have a small population,
there are not
going to be very many.
And to demonstrate that point,
can somebody identify some
other citizen of Switzerland who
rose to great heights, as
world-famous as [INAUDIBLE]?
Think of one other person?
I'm fairly pressed
to do so myself.
There's my uncle,
but he actually
didn't amount to much.
But there's an artist, Paul
Klee, who is world-class.
He was one of the early
modern artists.
And Switzerland has just
finished constructing a
marvelous museum on the
outskirts of the
capital city, Berne.
It's a structure that is
supposed to mimic the rolling
countryside of the central
part of Switzerland.
So it's a series of cylindrical
structures, glass
in front, glass on top.
And it divides the
area into three.
Two of them are exhibit spaces
and one is a space for
scholars and researchers.
And it's an absolutely
marvelous structure.
It appeared in the pages of Time
Magazine when it opened
[INAUDIBLE] about
two months ago.
Anyway, Euler was born
in 1707, so he
operated a long time ago.
And he died in St. Petersburg
on September 18, 1783.
That is exactly 350 years and
one day after my birthday.
That's another remarkable
thing about him.
He was 76 years old
when he died.
And that time of primitive
medicine and plague, not many
people got to live to
their 60s and 70s.
Euler studied at the University
of Basel under the
Bernoullis.
I think you've all heard
of the Bernoullis.
There's a very famous principle
of physics known as
the Bernoulli effect, which
stated in its simple practical
form says that if you have the
Sunday paper on the front seat
alongside of you, and you
drive your car with the
windows down, the paper will
blow out the window.
That's Bernoulli's principle
in action.
Euler got his doctorate
from Basel at age 16.
It sort of leads one to the
rhetorical question, how come
you guys have been spinning
your wheels for so long?
But then I said, he was
an unusual individual.
The Bernoullis went to St.
Petersburg in Russia, under
Catherine the First.
Russia was trying very hard at
that time to enter the ranks
of the Western world
as a full member.
Euler followed them a
little bit later on.
And he succeeded one of the
Bernoullis as a professor of
mathematics in 1733.
Then unfortunately, two years
later in 1735, he lost the
sight of one eye.
And why?
Because at that time, astronomy
had been using this
newfangled telescope which had
recently been perfected.
One of the hottest things going
was studying the heavens
looking through a telescope.
And if you wanted to look at the
sun, people knew nothing
about the damaging effect on
retinas of the sun's rays.
So he lost the sight
of one eye.
1741, he went back to Europe
again, to Berlin.
Why?
Because the reigning monarch
in Russia at that time was
called Ivan the Terrible, and
that says reams about why
Euler would want to
get out of Russia.
But then 1776, he went back to
St. Petersburg under the next
monarch, who was Catherine
the Great.
And that says why one would
be interested to go back.
Finally, in 1766, he
went fully blind.
Did that slow him down?
Not one bit.
He published in his lifetime
800 papers.
You talk to some big cheese
around MIT, they've published
maybe 200 or 300 papers, and
that with the assistance of an
army of graduate students, and
also, one might add, the
assistance of Xerox machines
and word processors.
So back in the days when you
wrote everything out by hand
with a [INAUDIBLE] quill pen,
800 papers is an absolutely
unbelievable accomplishment.
It took 35 years after he
passed away to publish
everything that he'd written.
People had kept busy publishing
what he did.
And among his accomplishments,
he was one of the first people
to apply real hardcore
mathematics to astronomy, to
make it quantitative.
He was one of the first to
suggest that light was a wave
form, and that color was a
function of wave length.
That was astonishingly
precocious.
And then, lest he seem like an
egghead who spent all his time
staring through telescopes and
working out theorems to use in
crystallography, he also wrote
a popular account of science
for the general public, which
was published in 1768.
And that book was published
for 90 years, three
generations of people kept
gobbling up [INAUDIBLE]
pretty good.
He impinged upon our own
language and activities in
several important ways.
He was the one who used
lowercase i to define the
square root of minus 1.
We can thank Euler for that.
He was the person who used
e to define the constant,
2.71828182845904523536.
And he was the person
who first used f
to stand for function.
So he contributed not only a lot
of good mathematics, but a
lot [INAUDIBLE].
So this does not have
to be easy.
Euler was a great guy.
And this geometry of rotations
about different axes is
something that also survives in
a mechanism that involves
achieving angular core rotation
on a axis by rotation
on two orthogonal arcs.
And that's something that's
called an Euler Cradle.
And that is geometry that;s
used in a great number of
mechanical devices.
In any case, back to instruction
for our purposes.
The thing that we would like
to do is let alpha and beta
take on all possible
crystallographic values,
namely 360 degrees or onefold
axis, although we know that
that's not gonna work.
Twofold, 180 degrees.
Threefold, 120.
Fourfold, 90.
Sixfold, 60.
And let that give the values
to alpha and beta,
taking two at a time.
And then let us ask the
question, at what angle should
we combine these two axes
to get gamma to be a
crystallographic
rotation axis?
And if it is crystallographic
and not something like 37.9234
degrees, what are the remaining
axes with interaxial
angles B and A?
So this is the problem that
Euler's construction solved.
And I won't go through all
the arguments that we
need to set this up.
But what we found after some f
sleight of hand when we were
working on the polar triangle
with spherical trigonometry,
what we found was the result
that said that if we want to
combine two axes, alpha and
beta, so that the third one
turned out to be a rotation of
gamma, then the cosine of the
angle between A and B should
be the cosine of alpha/2,
cosine of beta/2 plus cosine
of gamma/2, divided by the
sine of alpha/2, sine beta/2.
So if you pick your alpha and
beta, and you decide what you
would want these first two
rotations to turn out to be.
And generally it's
not gonna work.
But there are a surprising
number of cases
where it does work.
So you specify the combination
you had.
You also determine the angle
between A and C. And you have
to also determine the angle
between the axes B and C. And
there are similar sorts of
expressions that one obtains
simply by [INAUDIBLE] alpha
and beta again.
So then we set it up just by
looking at all possible
combinations of twofold, of two
different rotation axes,
and a third, which the
net effect might be.
We're not interested in
permuting A, B, and C. And A
equal to C equal to B is just
as interesting or not as A
equal to B equal to C. We don't
care about permutations.
And we generated-- just
as we [INAUDIBLE]
a week and a half ago-- a set of
combinations that we should
consider, what the axis A would
be, what the axis B
would be, and them different
choices for the axis C. So A
could be 1.
B could be 1.
And we could look for 1,
1, 1; 1, 1, 2; 1, 1, 3;
1, 1, 4; 1, 1, 6.
Those are legitimate
combinations?
Those are absurd combinations,
because doing nothing about
the first onefold axis, doing
nothing about the second
onefold axis could hardly result
in the net effect of
the 90-degree rotation
by the third axis.
And [INAUDIBLE] suggested is
that sitting around and doing
nothing twice was equal to a
rotation [INAUDIBLE] its
junctures [INAUDIBLE] we'd find
ourselves spinning on our
axis like tops.
Twofold axis.
1, 1, 2, we have here,
so we don't have to
consider 2, 1, 1.
But we should consider 2, 1,
2; 2, 1, 3; 2, 1, 4; 2,
1, 6, and so on.
If we filled out this whole
table, last time you got a
copy of it and some notes, and
all that remains then is to
quote [INAUDIBLE]
and see where we get allowable
axial combinations.
And not surprisingly, there
are so very, very few.
And we showed-- again, when we
finished up last time-- that
you can always take any n-fold
axis that has a C gamma that's
equal to C 2 pi over n and
combine it with twofold axes
at right angles, provided you
make the angle between the
twofold axes equal 2
of gamma over 2.
So the crystallographic
possibilities for C are, first
of all, C could be a twofold
axis, in which case you could
combine with it a pair of
twofold axes, and this 1/2 of
180 degrees would also
be a right angle.
We could let C be a threefold
axis, in which case the
twofold axes have to be at
right angles, two- to
threefold axes.
And they should be combined at
half the angular throw of the
threefold axes, which
is 60 degrees.
Two more possibilities are
four [INAUDIBLE] pair of
twofold axes at right angles.
Of the angle between them,
half of the throw of a
fourfold axis would have to
be equal to 5 degrees.
And the last one is sixfold
axis with a
pair of twofold axes.
Add angles to it.
And a third [INAUDIBLE].
So notice the insidious fact
that the angle between the
twofold axes is always a half,
1/2 the rotation angle in
principal axis C are not equal
to this rotation axis.
The other thing we saw that is
that these twofold axes are
different, distinct,
symmetry-independent axes.
They're different in that the
principal axis C never rotates
this axis into the second one,
and therefore demands that
whatever's going on around one
twofold axis be identical to
what's going on at the other
twofold axis, different in the
sense that they function in
different ways in the pattern,
or if you're describing the
symmetry of an object.
So probably the best
demonstration of this is a
regular prism with a triangular
shape or with a
square shape or with
a hexagonal shape.
And the adjacent twofold axes
for these prisms would come
out of the normal to a face.
And then if the second twofold
axis is going to be 45 degrees
away from the first, the other
one has to come [INAUDIBLE].
So yeah, they function in
different ways in the space.
One is normal to the face of
a regular prism, if that's
what's in our space.
The other one comes
out of the edge.
Similarly for a sixfold axis,
a hexagonal prism has one
twofold axis coming out normal
to a face, the adjacent
twofold axis coming
out to an edge.
And as advertised,
that angle is 33.
So they function in
different ways.
The only exception to that,
again, is the [INAUDIBLE]
threefold axis.
And the twofold axes there,
which were 60 degrees, come
out of one side from a corner
of the triangular prism.
On the other side, that
was [INAUDIBLE].
So all of the twofold axes
were the same thing.
There's only one independent
kind of twofold axis, just as
there was only kind of mirror
plane in the combination of a
mirror plane passing through
a twofold axis.
The names for these are always,
as we've done in the
past, a running list of the
independent symmetry
operations that are present.
So this general one, n, 2, 2,
with the n-fold axis for some
generic sort of a
twofold axis.
This one would be 2, 2, 2.
This one would be 4, 2, 2.
And this one would be 6, 2, 2.
This [INAUDIBLE] with a
threefold axis is, again,
called not 3, 2, but 3, 2,
because there's only one kind
of twofold axis, just as
there's only one kind
[INAUDIBLE].
We pause [INAUDIBLE], see if
you have any questions.
These are the crystallographic
combinations of this
[INAUDIBLE].
There is no reason why you
should not in something that
doesn't have to be compatible
with a lattice, combine an
n-fold axis of any sort with
twofold axes or right angles.
And indeed, if I look at my
old friend, the saguaro
cactus, we can add
anything like 28-
up to 32-fold symmetry.
This cactus stem had
a 28-fold symmetry.
It would be a twofold axis
coming out of the string with
one of the ribs, another twofold
axis coming out of the
crevice between the pair
of these ribs.
And if I took that thing up,
very carefully because of the
spines, and with great effort
because it weights several
tons, and rotated it about one
axis, and then rotate it again
about a second axis, turning
it upside-down, [INAUDIBLE]
axis would be rotation
to 128 [INAUDIBLE].
Valid symmetry, but not
crystallographic.
OK, any comments or questions?
Get to know these results,
because the exercise that's
going to occupy us for the
next week is going to be
asking how we can decorate these
frameworks with mirror
planes and with inversion.
If you want orientation, we
could add another operation to
the collection of axes
while it pops up.
Where [INAUDIBLE].
Comments or questions?
OK, there are only two other
combinations that are
crystallographic that
involve directions
that are not simple.
And one of them involves a
combination of a threefold
axis with twofold axes that come
out of directions at a
normal to the face of a cube.
So these turn out to be very,
very strange angles which make
no sense at all until
you refer them to
directions in the cube.
The direction of the threefold
axis turns out to be
correspondent with the
angle of a cube.
The direction of the twofold
axis corresponds to
the normal two faces.
You can show--
I did show, and I don't think
anybody really followed me, so
I had to hand out that
[INAUDIBLE]--
that if you start with one
twofold axis and one threefold
axis, what you're going to get
is a threefold axis coming out
of all of the [INAUDIBLE]
diagonals, but they're all
equivalent to this
threefold axis.
And twofold axes come out
to normal for all the
faces of the cube.
So there's only one kind of
twofold axis and one kind of
threefold axis, so even though
we got this by combining a
pair of twofold axes--
I'm sorry, a pair of
threefold axes--
that's what happens when
you stay up late.
You forget about this one.
A pair of threefold axes
at the diagonals
and one twofold axis.
And this is the combination
that is called 23, because
there's only one sort of twofold
axis and one sort of
threefold axis.
And I'd like to point out and
I'd like to warn you of traps
when we come across them, make
sure we don't [INAUDIBLE]
across them.
Notice the insidious relation
of this pair of integers to
the symmetry that we
label [? 232. ?]
32 is a threefold axis with a
twofold axis normal to it.
23 is this combination
that involves
corrections in a cube.
Now, let me pause
parenthetically with an aside.
You might say, how
can this be?
Here is a cube.
That cube has got a fourfold
axis about it.
Don't call that a
twofold axis.
A cube has a fourfold axis
coming out of it.
OK, let me give you an
example in real life.
There is a fairly common
mineral, iron disulfide--
pyrite.
This forms nice, shiny cubes,
but the cube faces have
striations on them.
If you look at them, there's a
set of lines running this way.
And what those lines are if you
look at this crystal face
with a magnifying glass, is that
these are little steps of
a second face.
And this is a face
of the form hk0.
And this oscillates back and
forth, and there seem to be
lines scribed on the surface.
So this sort of a [INAUDIBLE]
crystal growth of one face which
never really develops is
not that uncommon.
There's a threefold axis coming
out of the corner here,
but this is really a surface
that is left at variant only
by 183 [INAUDIBLE].
You cannot rotate that
surface 90 degrees.
The orientation of the
lines have changed.
But there is a bona fide
threefold axis coming up
there, so these striations, if
I rotate them to this face,
will go in a way like this.
This edge turns into this edge,
and therefore the lines
will run down like this.
And if I rotate [INAUDIBLE] n by
90 degrees, the striations
on the adjacent face
will run down.
So there's a decorated cube.
And if you rolled it up and say
how can I move this cube
around and leave its appearance
totally unchanged?
the answer is, rotate it by
120 degrees [INAUDIBLE]
diagonal.
But we can only rotate it 180
degrees around the face.
So there's an example of
a crystal [INAUDIBLE]
on the arrangement of
rotation axes 23.
The final one, the highest
symmetry of all, involves a
fourfold axis coming out of a
direction normal to a face, a
threefold axis coming out of the
[INAUDIBLE] diagonal, and
a twofold axis coming out
normal to an edge.
And if you let these axes work
on one another, there's a
twofold axis that comes out of
every edge, and a fourfold
axis that comes out
of every face.
And this one is named 432,
because it's a combination of
a fourfold, a threefold,
and a twofold.
That is the symmetry
to the cube.
And for crystallographic
symmetries, that's about as
complicated as it gets.
Now, if we look at the regular
solids that we've encountered
here, with symmetry 23, there
is a regular [INAUDIBLE]
consisting of four
triangular faces.
That's a tetrahedron.
And for 432, one of the
polyhedra that can form from
the crystal [INAUDIBLE]
is an octahedron.
These were the lovely solids
called Platonic solids, after
Plato, that we used as our
trophies early this afternoon.
So this is an octahedron.
Let me finish up before our
break by asking is there any
other regular polyhedra that can
result from a combination
of rotation axes that are
not crystallographic?
Now, that's a tough
question to ask.
You instantly scan your
knowledge of geometry.
Clearly, there are a lot
of prisms [INAUDIBLE]
infinite number of prisms
[INAUDIBLE] n22.
But there's only one other
combination of axes
non-crystallographic which
results in a regular
polyhedron.
And this is a combination,
believe it or not, of a
fivefold axis with
a threefold axis.
This is a fivefold axis
and a threefold axis
and a twofold axis.
And these result in a regular
solid called an icosahedron.
And that is so complicated
that I won't
attempt to draw it.
But having said so, it
looks like this.
It has diamond-shaped faces.
And there are five of these
that come together in a
[INAUDIBLE] form.
So here's one of the [INAUDIBLE]
diamond-shaped
faces, another diamond-shaped
face, and then the two other
ones that come in like this.
So there are 1, 2, 3, 4,
5 faces, so this is the
orientation of a
fivefold axis.
The twofold axis comes out of
a place where two of these
edges are shared.
And the threefold axis--
[INAUDIBLE] triangular faces.
[INAUDIBLE].
So here's the fivefold axis.
These are the twofold
axes [INAUDIBLE].
And these are threefold axes.
But you know all this.
Is there anybody
who [INAUDIBLE]
show me that they've never
seen an icosahedron?
Anybody ever who has not seen--
have you seen it?
[INAUDIBLE].
Here--
I spared no expense-- is a live
icosahedron for those who
would like to look.
AUDIENCE: How many sides
does it have?
PROFESSOR: He'll count
them for you.
I don't remember.
I know the number of faces and
the number of edges, but not
the [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
faces.
PROFESSOR: I think it's--
I'm not sure [INAUDIBLE].
Not sure.
AUDIENCE: But you said you
know the number of faces.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, but I can't
tell you everything I know
[INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
PROFESSOR: There's another
figure which also has this
symmetry, and it's
a regular solid.
And this is called a rhombic
dodecahedron.
And, wise guy, this
has 12 faces.
And the faces are pentagonal.
And there are three pentagonal
faces that come together at
the threefold axis, a fivefold
axis out of each of the
pentagonal faces, and a twofold
axis out of the edges.
The face that this has 12 faces
at regular intervals
leads an entrepreneur who was
familiar with injection
molding to cast these little
things as a plastic, and then
puts a month of the year on each
of the 12 faces and made
a nice little desk calendar.
[INAUDIBLE] something that
reminds you of symmetry as
well [INAUDIBLE].
So this has fivefold faces,
12 of them, and that's the
rhombic dodecahedron as
opposed to the normal
dodecahedron which
is [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: So are those
both [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: I'm sorry?
AUDIENCE: Are those
both [INAUDIBLE]?
The icosahedron, [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this has a
fivefold axis coming out of
the pentagonal [INAUDIBLE].
Is that what you're asking?
And the threefold axis, there
are three of them that, come
together, and they do
something like this.
So here's the threefold, here's
the fivefold, here's
the twofold.
Here we have to see
it [INAUDIBLE].
Look for somebody who's got one
of these desk calendars.
[INAUDIBLE] used to sell them.
[INAUDIBLE].
OK, this sets up the next
stage of our game.
We've got these arrangements
of axes.
And if you count them up on the
fingers of your hands and
one toe, there are 11 of them.
There are the axes by
themselves-- onefold, twofold,
threefold, fourfold, sixfold.
There are these so-called
dihedral combinations, where
the only thing that changes from
one to the other is the
symmetry of the main axis, the
[INAUDIBLE] symmetry, and
therefore the dihedral angle
between the twofold axes.
And these are 222,
32, 422, and 622.
And then the two cubic
arrangements, 32 and 432.
So when we return, we'll ask the
question, how can we add
mirror planes for an inversion
center to this
combination of axes?
And these are going to give us
new symmetries involving not
only rotation, but [INAUDIBLE]
help with rotation
inversion as well.
And the constraint in doing this
is that we have to add
the reflection plane and the
inversion center in such a way
that it doesn't create any new
rotation axes, because we have
systematically derived all of
the possible combinations of
crystallographic
rotation axes.
So if the addition of a mirror
plane, creates a new axis,
that's going to be something
that you already have with a
combination of a greater number
of rotation axes.
For example, if you take a
single twofold axis and a
mirror plane of an angle, that
generated another twofold axis
90 degrees away.
But we've already got that.
If a mirror plane moves an axis
to an angle that doesn't
correspond to one of these
arrangements, it's going to be
impossible, because we have
systematically derived, using
Euler's construction, all the
combinations of rotation
operations that are possible.
So that's going to be
the constraint.
We want to add mirror planes or
an inversion center in all
possible combinations.
And this means we're gonna
need a theorem.
What happens when you
add a mirror plane
to a rotation operation?
We're already familiar
with one of them.
You take an axis and you pass
an mirror plane through it,
you get another mirror plane
that is rotated about the
axis, away from the first,
by half the rotation
angle of the axis.
So let's take a breather,
and let us
resume in about 10 minutes.